i am so excited that you're here i
really really
i've been so looking forward to this and
uh
we're just so excited to have a
conversation with you i'm so inspired by
your
entrepreneurial ways and i feel like i'm
so glad that you wrote the book about it
um because i think people really want to
have a guide in this world of how they
too themselves could figure out how to
navigate business you know in the
beginning i was a resistance to doing
anything like in the self-help area
because i felt like the you know people
that
usually do that kind of see themselves
as experts right and then when i get a
chance to talk about some of the
mistakes i made
it kind of made me comfortable doing it
because then it's like to prevent people
from
making similar mistakes to me it's what
made me actually like the category a
little better um well
you started
executive producing a show called power
i feel like as a consumer that you
single-handedly like i just turned
british too
hauntedly
that you single-handedly
really made me focus on stars network
you really put them on the map you
really put them to the forefront
um
and that must be a very good feeling
yeah it's cool like when the network
when you go there in the early stages
and you kind of and it blossoms and
grows then they they'll start to listen
to you
you know they start to want more content
from you because they've had success
with everything that you offered but
power
i didn't with the success of the series
i convinced them that they that it was a
universe
like marvel yes like that i can do
multiples and that people appreciate and
enjoy and and stars they came to mandate
it's a premium woman's mandate so it's
like they look at the content from a
different perspective and lens and
they're saying it has to be
for women for people we have to have
strong female characters as that offer
something that pulls on the strings of
your your heart your feelings when
you're actually doing it so even when
the story has males in it
oh they have to be attractive males
like ghosts and like in the power series
they said no you absolutely has to be
attractive or get them out of here
it's gotta be for women and the men have
to be hot
you were able to build a franchise which
you know in the industry is is huge it's
really everything it it gives you um a
credibility kind of like nothing else
um and you were able to convince them
that it was a universe and you got
spin-off shows and
i mean that's that's a very big feat yes
well five
yeah five shows five shows
[Applause]
i wanna ask about the new and latest and
greatest um bmf in your franchise belt
at stars i'm excited about it these guys
they went on to be
huge drug dealers hugely successful in
it and their choices when you they're
both brothers uh terry and reach
flannery and when you go back into the
the origin story of it they they come
from a christian family
that uh struggled with one child making
the decision to do things that they feel
like was going in the wrong direction
and his brother
would just follow them into it and it's
a it's a
family drama but it's complex because of
the choices of the children
and uh they grow into
full-blown adults and the things that
they say that you'll get when you choose
that lifestyle you're being dead or in
jail or
were what actually
took place but um
you know they did
the indictment fell in 2005 and they
received 30 years of peace
oh my gosh i i've been watching the show
it's it's um
i'm glad you're not you know putting a
veneer on it you're telling it like it
is you're talking about a true story
it's shot beautifully it's very
cinematic
um it's very dynamic you actually
directed an episode um episode seven
yeah who happens to have someone in it
who
uh marshall mathis i got eminem
[Applause]
uh
i heard he just texts you random texts
throughout the day he does call me every
now and then
can i ask what a said random marshall
mathers text is oh he might see
something i'm doing like like uh i'm on
the drew barrymore show
and he'd be like yo you was right there
how was it
that girl said something to me um should
we text him right now
is that awkward
okay wait uh here does he likes videos
or does he prefer words
let's pick the video everyone okay okay
okay see this is how good i am at this
okay
oh you look good in there they're going
i do
okay thank you
um hi marshall we just felt compelled to
text you yeah we live on tv this big dog
status stuff going on here
here's everybody
[Applause]
saying hello and
because i found out you sent
curtis random texts we thought we would
send you one yeah and look i'm sending
you
videos with really hot attractive women
in them
you need to send me something back i'd
like to see a video in return
[Applause]
oh my gosh i was like this is so funny
he gonna owe me big time
well i'm so glad that you guys are
such geniuses and that you're friends
and collaborating and putting wonderful
stuff out into the world in such
multi-faceted ways we actually have a
clip of this truly eye-opening um
amazing show please take a look
yeah my don't forget i need money for
that pablo trip
we'll talk about it later that's what
you said last week hey look nikki don't
even trip i got you we're not taking
your money pop's just for our school
field trip did i stutter terry
how was school today
it was good we gonna be on the honor
roll again right
make sure last semester wasn't no fluke
it's
truly a beautifully shot show thank you
thank you so much
um bmf air sundays on stars it has just
been such a blast to hang play talk
everything is so much fun like i've done
i just did jimmy kimmel he ain't as cool
[Applause]
[Music]